all rise your honorable judge would
never mind this first case number three
to six
that one's boring I want the TV station
one Pamela wolf who the W was silent
when you say it maybe you're suing a
station Lucy Lou first became a
household name playing Ling Wu in the
emmy-winning series Ally McBeal her
best-known work also includes hit movies
like Charlie's Angels and Kill Bill Liu
stars in the CBS crime drama elementary
as dr. Joan Watson Sherlock Holmes's
investigative partner and in tonight's
sixth season premiere Watson confronts
Holmes about his bizarre behavior after
the recent death of an associate I bet
you wouldn't you know you're gonna
acting like such a jerk since Shane wall
died and when I called you on it what
was your response avoiding me for weeks
no we're not doing this on your terms
you want to talk that's fine it's an
open room right here I'm not well
I'll tell you everything she's not here
ah good morning I'll tell you everything
so just to remind everybody last season
the end Sherlock Holmes is suffering
from hallucinations right because he's
been assaulted and now he's ill what's
wrong with him
well we find out that Sherlock who's
played by Jonny Lee Miller who's
fantastic and just a darling
it basically is suffering from
concussions and so his mind is not his
own and it changes the game up because
he's the one who innately knows and
detects and is able to discover and come
up with ideas that nobody else could to
discover you know who basically who done
it so what happens when he's not on par
with his usual self and how does that
affect you yeah your relationship I
think that he has to also be able to
trust and be open to more people's
opinions and he has also rely on on
Watson as a friend and also be open to
being vulnerable because it's very scary
when you can't be who you are at your
best and that's all he knows how to do
so suddenly he's in a situation where
you know he can't trust if you remembers
or if he did speak to someone or you
know how do you end up doing it it
becomes very scary it's terrifying for
anyone I think right his chief tool is
called into question yes you said that
your character Watson is the most
patient role you've been able to play
what is what does that mean I think the
development of this character has been a
much more a much more of a progression
so she basically as somebody who was the
sober companion and then she became you
know she's more of a witness than
someone who I've played before which you
know you had a clip of lingual earlier
and she's very decisive and very
aggressive and powerful yeah impatient
but it's a very different way to to sort
of you know discover a character and so
this is a very patient character as far
as I'm concerned is in my career at
least this new role in filling the gaps
in Holmes's mental problems call for a
more assertive Watson now I think that
she just has to be more aggressive as a
friend and make sure that he listens to
her and take
that she's able to take care of him more
and I think he's so independent and
fiercely independent to the point where
she some sometimes has to kind of come
in and say I'm gonna do this and you're
gonna do this you're also directing two
episodes of the show this season I
directed two episodes and starting from
season 6 season 2 I was directing so
I've had a great opportunity to be a
part of a different side of your show
which I've enjoyed greatly you like it
more than acting or is it just different
I love acting I don't know if I'll ever
not love it I have such a passion for it
but I have grown to really appreciate
directing because you really get to work
together in a team environment with the
head of the departments and the crew and
I don't know everything sort of comes
together and the coherence of that
really opens up your world and you you
really are activating every part of your
brain let's talk about you Lucy Liu
how's two-year-old Rock well oh he's
great he's great I mean he's running
around you know he's been in school he's
very independent comes off that he comes
to the set and he I mean he's at the
point now that you know they're very
honest and they'll be directing is this
morning I'm getting ready goes mommy why
do you look like a monkey I know
okay well hair makeup you know that's
what's happening right now and he tells
me he loves me so much all the time I
mean these are things that I want a
bottle because they're so special and
they're coming I'm not prompting him
he's not really right there not for a
month just melts your heart you know
they're not like always good to see you
thank you congratulations ladies
Elementary premieres tonight at 10:00
9:00 central here on CBS